il est entré dans nos vies depuis le 9
août dernier le pass and iter le pass
sanitaire passe sanitaire le passé huit
heures et oui le pass and i ter ce
précieux sésame qui permet désormais aux
français de se rendre au restaurant au
cinéma ou encore de voyager sur liberty
sera salutaire
et si ce nouveau bras droit ne plaît pas
à tout le monde gare aux plus
réfractaires car sa possible utilisation
pourrait être prolongé c'est ce que
préconise le gouvernement et qui devrait
être présenté au conseil des ministres
13 octobre prochain comme l'a indiqué le
porte-parole gabriela talent que nous
allons proposer au parlement c'est de
maintenir pendant plusieurs mois encore
jusqu'à l'été la possibilité d'y
recourir une réflexion des libertés un
comptable qui a déjà trop duré pour
certains opposants alors êtes vous
favorable à la prolongation du pass
anita jusqu'à l'été
merci
oui merci d'être là médecin essayiste et
gérard délépine docteur merci d'être là
girard alors êtes vous favorable à la
prolongation du pass and i ter jusqu'à
cet été s'il vous plaît à voilà on
allait alors je voudrais d'abord qu'on
est où on fera les lélés les suceurs
après on va d'abord démarré par
guillaume et si on accepte sanitaire
jusqu'à l'été 2001 2 c'est à dire qu'on
accepte avis et surtout qu'on accepte de
pourrir la vie de tous les français qui
refusent de sélectionner ou qui refusent
de faire un test pcr qui est désormais
payant je le rappelle pour moi se passa
par diviser la société enfreint le
secret médical et mettre des gens au
chômage que je rappelle qu'il ya des
gens qui ont perdu leur emploi à cause
de ce pass sanitaires il ne sert
absolument à rien d'autant plus qu'ils
aient une recrudescence de faux passe en
ce moment donc c'est un échec total mais
alors moi et j'ai une question qui vient
de tomber et qui est vachement
importante c est ce qu on aura le droit
de voter si on n'a pas le pas salutaire
surtout que les élections ce sera en
avril mais moi je suis sûr que bien sûr
que non très bonnes questions et j'ai
directement on veut nous avons léger on
veut imposer les votes par
correspondance qui est le meilleur moyen
c'est de truquer les élections et ce qui
s'est passé mais c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec trucks non mais attendez
c'est la région on crie pas au complot
sur tout mais on peut quand même se
poser la question mine de rien il n'est
pas prévu que de restrictions au droit
de vote etc et par équipes sur les sens
qu'il n'est pas il n'est pas possible
d'interdire aux gens je reparte et sinon
sanitaire je crois pas excuse moi
laurent excuse moi laurent mais je pense
que ce sera du vote par coeur pour
égaliser et puis d'autre part n'oublie
pas que on parle de prolongation dépasse
sanitaire c'est pas une prolongation du
pass sanitaire jusqu'à l'été c'est la
possibilité si elle recrudescence de
l'épidémie mais bon on l'utilisé le
parlement dans l'émoi qu'a noté gérard
temps de faire beaucoup se réunir bien
l'élection présidentielle qui arrivent
et donc c'est une mesure préventive
c'est pas du tout une certitude qu'ils
soient activés jusqu'à l'été prochain
alors juste laurent s'il évoque on sait
comment ça se passe c'est comme quand tu
dis à ton fils voilà peut-être qu'à noël
tu vas pas partir en vacances parce
qu'on va faire autre chose tu sais très
bien que tu commences à le préparer nous
ils commencent à nous dire voilà on
pense que le passage au caire sera
jusqu'à ce que je suis ce que tu sors
mais il ya des régions comme la guyane
ouais mais ont-ils taux de vaccination
est 20% et où l'épidémie est grave et où
il est possible que le passé ni terre
soit maintenu longtemps jeu pendant ce
qui concerne la france métropolitaine il
est où il est vraiment très peu probable
qu'ils soient maintenues jusqu'à l'été
est démis en france actuellement est
proche de zéro et gert-jan réveille toi
tu t'appelles pas gilles tête
c'est ça la démocratie
alors donc bien sûr que il va y avoir
prolongation puisque l'état d'urgence
sanitaire va être prolongée duratti
route mais il n'ya plus d'urgence mais
il ya une loi d'urgence laissez moi
finir mais cherchera donc c'est sûr que
ça va être prolongée et moi je suis pour
bien sûr il faut le prolonger il faut
même le durcir moi j'ai été meurtri
parce que je suis allé récemment dans un
resto on ne m'a pas demandé mon pass
sanitaires je les montre et sans qu'on
me le demande non mais je suis pour
durcir gérard il faut durcir et il faut
aussi bien entendu une troisième dose de
respect de ne pas agir à un fou durcir
cesser les gens car il passe alors
girard vous rigolez vous fait marrer la
haye où il me fait vraiment marrer parce
que les pays qui utilisent le passage du
ter ou depuis une augmentation des
contaminations donc je me chif regardez
donc les résultats de l' oms sur
l'autriche l'autriche a instauré un
impact sanitaire le 1er juillet il avait
accepté pas combien de contamination par
jour sans on au triangle à nice matin
2000 et ça a monté dix jours après le
pass le pass sert à faire croire aux
gens qu'ils sont protégés donc tu
pourrais toujours une précaution quand
vous allez dans votre restaurant comme
l'hôtel parce vous dites je suis peinard
way est bien celle à la grave erreur ça
s'est vu dans plein d'endroits je vous
donne l'exemple de r majesté queen
elizabeth porte avions ils s'arrêtent
tous les marins ont été vaccinés ils ont
tous eu leur dose depuis plus de trois
mois donc c'est des gens qui sont
tranquilles ils n'auraient ils pas sans
problème il s'arrête à chypre ils
repartent et cinq jours plus tard 120
nouveaux cas de contamination combien de
morts pas parce que des jeunes de babel
d'envoyer attendez attendez les jeunes
et parents en aucun cas grave
parviendrez à mais non mais
c'est les marins jeunes arrêter de
déconner il ya aussi des cannettes sur
les marins les marins et les régions
touchées tout
allons nous avons eu nous le char de
gaulle une épidémie avec 2000 cas je
sais il ya eu aucun mort alors ne me
dites pas que c'est le vaccin qui a
permis de pas voir des morts les marins
et les morses et les gens de plus de 65
ans alors oui il ya eu quatre enfants
qui sont morts d'un an mais il ya eu des
formes de gratte sur des gens plus
jeunes et
oui alors le problème c'est que vous
regardez la prise de la prétention que
le vaccin protège des formes graves est
un mensonge absolu regardez ce qui se
passe en israël ils sont tous deux
certains trois doses et il se retrouve
en réalisant des forêts
alors la chute
avant de rentrer
castaldi sur les règles c'est très
simple je vous dis vous dites n'importe
quoi c'est rsa avait oublié de la
dépasse souvent les civils
ils nettoient pas ils les voient
ressources aux personnes l'écouté ce qui
vous dire sur 100 personnes y en a 90 2
de vacciner disent qu'ils ne sont pas
faux fond attendant ils sont placés
autour de laurence boccolini et en fait
pourquoi il ya des gens
ça va venir ou pas oui oui assure c'est
directement est décédé il y en a quatre
qui sont effectivement rien et alors que
d'oyonnax y en a un ou deux qui sont
vaccinées donc la proportion est
beaucoup plus fort que vous dites
n'importe castaldi vous êtes le maillon
faible
non mais juste laurent laurent
qu'est ce que vous dites de salah parce
que c'est vrai qu'on entend plein de
chiffres on entend plein de choses à
acheter je dirais franchement
moi je dirai ce que j'ai entendu chez
toi bonsoir mais lépine il y à quelques
temps a dit cette épidémie a été
inventée non par des gens qui voulaient
vendre 15 milliards de vaccins s'est
installée la dictature salita illanes et
edison a dit julie si j'ai pas de cadeau
pour toi tu n'as ni du délai un banc
l'elysée qui n'en sais rien à la donne à
jour le mardi qui est mort il peut
réunion d alain à l'émission qui est
disponible sur youtube et donc effectué
six jours
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tunisia sur youtube
allez sur youtube à l'émission sa
tourelle syrie quand tu penses comme
gérard des lipides ou et qu' il ya un
grand complot mondial de jim les
gouvernements du monde jamais douté a
tenté la maladie pour installer une
dictature mais c'était dimanche
facilitée avec sinon c'est extrêmement
étrange paralysie c'est mon léger je
suis trop car je n'ai jamais douté
qu'elle n'existe pas il faut bien qu'ils
aient un con et je vous l'avais tout
léger vers le monde d'aller chez calme
toi ici c'est une grippe de l'ordre de
la grippe c'est là qu'on a dit ça je lui
donnais pas dit que ce n'était pas une
maladie mais j attends je laisse moi je
lis tu l'as dit ça le complot aurait été
ici je m'en rappelle non j'ai composé du
ccg temps pas avoir à manger jouer
je joue mais tout cela
c'est
chaud là où tu peux blanc et dans les
heureux nantes a dédié un moment qu'on
peut supposer qu'il y ait un contour
c'est totalement différent c'est pas une
affirmation c'est un à côté c'est ça si
tu sais pas me le confiait le
complotisme c'est ça c'est du tueur est
susurré des contrevérités pour semer le
doute
c'est aussi des hypothèses très tout à
fait digne de l'ordre de celle de
pasteur qui nous on doit avoir une
quatrième vague avec chaque jour 5000
personnes qui vont à l'hôpital en
septembre à nous sommes ans et alors
c'est bien du coup et oui alors c'est
bien ou c'est pas bien jusqu'où quoi bah
du coup mais pas sanitaires non ça vous
sentir le manquer ça prouve simplement
que la prédiction était complètement
fausse comme celle du plan du rapport 9
de ferguson qui promettra qui
reste
avec son art et on vous avait prévu dans
la poêle autre chose qu on y est
comment
qu'en suède il y aurait 70 mille morts à
nous on est une autre prédiction disait
cent mille morts en suède s'il fermait
pas tout ils n'ont pas fermé exactement
ils sont à 14 8 morts se mouvait gerra
juste vraiment toi t'es pas pour le pass
and i ter jusqu'à cet été non parce que
je trouve que c'est une hypocrisie que
j'aurais préféré qu'on soit cash
j'aurais préféré qu'on me dise
obligation vaccinale pour une amende
plutôt que de faire des tours de passe
passe là-bas en disant ça ça ça pousse
les gens à la vaccination n'est pas
celle que 130 mille personnes qui vont
manifester si c'est que ce sont trente
mille personnes laissez les tranquilles
là j'ai appris une nouvelle lune un
autre truc là on dit que autant
comptable tenta le quant à la première
dose il ya des pubs partout qui passe à
la radio à la télé quand tu as fait
quant à elle qu vide et tu te suffit que
d'une seule dose allez on arrive là bas
on te dit faut une sérologie vous allez
avoir deux dos et on me parle d'une
troisième dose une quatrième dose ça
n'en finit pas moi j'aime pas cette idée
on allait me porte à patrice sur ton
téléphone tu peux pas le restant tu peux
pas le cinéma c'est pas des on voit bien
que c'est pas des lieux où tu attrapes
le coc vide au restaurant on le voit
bien et j'aime pas non plus voir sur un
cv recherchons chauffeur-livreur
caissière je sais pas quoi n'importe qui
est assistante de direction passe valide
et je n'aime pas voir ça sur 140 cv
quand tu es au chômage j'aime pas qu'on
te dise si t'as pas de pass à lithaire
tuera chez toi tu crèvent de faim j'aime
pas ce truc là je trouve que le garder
jusqu'à octobre novembre basse était une
bonne chose la prolonger et moi je le
dis comme toi je dis que aux élections
faudra un pass sanitaire gens super
temps mais c'est ça parce que j'aurai la
grande question qu'on se pose et je vous
dis est-ce que comment comment au
ressenti comment les citoyens ont
ressenti ça je vous le dis je le vois
sur les réseaux sociaux tout le monde
s'est dit ils veulent nous mettre une
carotte sur les élections balles à
johnny parce qu'ils se disent ils
veulent prolonger le pass and i ter
jusqu'à l'été les élections
présidentielles sont en avril et mai et
donc ils disent peut-être qu'on pourra
pas aller voter sans pass inter laurent
alexandre je sais je vous fais confiance
pratiquement aveugle mais je doute c'est
ludique c'est juridiquement un passé je
doute qu'on puisse aller dans un endroit
de dans un bureau de vote sans pas
sanitaires non je le masque l'agera
obligatoire si l'épidémie continue mais
il est il serait inconstitutionnelle
d'interdire l'entrée du bureau de vote
aux gens qui n'est point qui ne lui
persuadé qu'il va avoir une
aucun président de la firme publiquement
anticonstitutionnel à ce que vous ce
qu'il vient de dire ça veut absolument
rien dire que j'aurais jamais pensé
je suis sûr qu'ils peuvent faire une loi
il faut faire une loi un jour on te dit
si tu vas pas de vacciner demain je te
faut chômage tu dégage tu rentres chez
toi
ça se fait pas ça non mais
je te jure je j'espère que tu as raison
mais je suis pas aussi catégorique ce
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on est quand
même en train de sortir de l'épidémie
doucement on va peut-être avoir une
petite reçu c'est hélas en octobre 9h je
viens à faire plus froid mais la
situation
[Rires]
je suis honoré de plus toute sa tête
c'est vachement améliorée on peut
vraiment espérer qu'au moment de
l'élection présidentielle
on en sera sorti et que le pass and i
ter ne sera pas réactiver faut être un
petit peu ça voyez ça va quand même
mieux les restos sont ouverts on va au
cinéma
retrouver
il nous reste 53 secondes gérard qualité
de psychoter ça va mieux alors c'est
rare qu est-à-dire tu as 50 secondes mon
bébé ben je dis qu'un le pass sanitaire
n'est effectivement pas efficace dans
les pays qui l'ont appliquée donc j'ai
donné l'autriche qui a multiplié par
j'ai donné l'exemple de hache et de hms
des marins mais en plus non seul il est
il totalement illogique où vous croyez
que le vaccin marché vo droit le plus
strict vous vacciner vous foutez la paix
aux gens qui veulent pas excéder 50
millions personnes qui n'ont maxine et
non non non on était à qui on a beaucoup
à qui on a extorqué le consentement que
ça veut dire et ce quand on vous dit
vous n'allez pas travailler demain non
vous c'est votre droit le plus strict
vous avez loin vous êtes une gentille
romy
[Musique]
70% non il va noyer ou pas donc voilà
vous êtes complètement à côté de la
plaque autour de la table il ya les gens
sont plutôt non vous êtes voilà comme
d'habitude mais c'est vrai que vous vous
êtes plutôt des bons élèves voilà donc
c'est vrai
on